what's going on guys so I was just
thinking the other day the 90s was like
an awesome decade for movies we should
like do a screen junkies episode about
that so we're doing it like right now
and we have an awesome panel here to
talk about this topic from the new
sitcom on Fox surviving jack which takes
place in the 90s we have Rachel Harris
she plays Joanne Dunleavy hi Rachel hi
and then we have one of the co-creators
of the show
Patrick Schumacher hello hell and down
on the end he's not associated with
surviving jack but he was here sleeping
in the studio since last week Nick Mundy
Nick welcome back thank you today we're
gonna talk about 90s movies is there one
movie for you that you'd say oh this is
the ultimate 90s movie yeah well I mean
I was gonna say Jurassic Park is in our
pilot mom always knew just how to push
dad's buttons they escape from the
island and both the kids live you're
welcome
I beg to differ that Jurassic Park is
like a great 90s movie it transcends
time that movie I would agree with that
but Nick it came out in the 90s so it's
a great 90s minnow movie Nick okay just
don't screw me on this so everything is
here gonna be great movies we can't stop
and like you know make that
clarification every time thank you
you know what okay so let's learn from
Jurassic Park my movie pretty much of
all time would have to be um Goodfellas
some might say Scorsese's best Oh funny
how I mean funny like I'm a clown am you
you I make you laugh casino also came
out in the 90s some people have a casino
Goodfellas debate I don't think it's a
debate for me it's you know yeah
Goodfellas in a romp
Patrick is is there a movie that we
haven't mentioned that really screams
90s to you Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
to the secret of the ooze the sort of
seminal moment of that film was of
course vanilla ice up on stage doing the
ninja rap
it's like 90s product placement totally
vanilla ice in the scene you choreograph
a fight to the music with the turtles
the fact that you picked that gives me
that much greater respect for surviving
Jack 9:30 Fox Thursday nights because
before he was borderline Nick what movie
typifies the 90s most of all for you
demolition man this is most like
representative movie of the nineties
ever it has Sylvester Stallone trying it
has Rob Schneider in a funny role it has
dan Cortese in it also although from
Beetlejuice wasn't it you kind of look
like Oh throw a little bit yeah we threw
out some of our favorite 90s films now
let's break down a little bit by
category stop comedy Wayne's World 1992
that's my favorite movie of all time
isn't Milwaukee an Indian name yes Pete
it is actually it's pronounced Milwaukee
which is Algonquin for the good land I
was not aware of that my I had a senior
yearbook picture whatever and we were
allowed to have a quote under it uh-huh
and my quote was was it Kierkegaard or
dick Van Patten who said if you label me
you negate me that's all nobody got it
but hey screen junkies fans yearbooks
are like paper Facebook yeah you might
not it's like it's like paper Twitter
it's you turn the pages and your friends
are in there and you can sign them there
were there were a few comedians in the
90s who just had awesome triumphs so we
haven't talked about yet Ace Ventura
alrighty then oh yeah Jim Carrey that
was a huge that was his decade y'all
said the Cable Guy dum-dum yeah dum-dum
the masks Sandler that I think the 90s
was his best decade happy gilmore I must
have seen that movie like four times in
the theaters yeah you want a piece of me
I don't a piece you I want the whole
thing never saw it never saw happy
gilmore really yeah
or Billy Madison oh you're missing out
three classics I want to throw out there
three absolute classics from the 90s
Pulp Fiction Shawshank Redemption
Forrest Gump two classics and one big
pile of horse Forrest Gump Oscar winner
it's one of the worst movies ever
hey let's just make this real good feel
good early claptrap where we put you
know this person in events of history
and he just he doesn't react to anything
he just does it and then Jenny is just
the worst human being in the world she
just keeps taking advantage of forests
over and over she'd even tell him that
he had a son
I like Forrest Gump I think it's a it's
a great feel good movie but I do not
like the fact that it beat pulp fiction
for Best Picture that year beat Pulp
Fiction and Shawshank if memory serves
well I want to say those all three were
from 94 you know I want to shift gears
and talk about one of the best years one
of the ten best years of the 90s 1999
but it was actually a great year for
movies Blair Witch The Matrix Fight Club
American Beauty some might say M night
Shyamalan only good movie came out in
the 90s The Sixth Sense another movie
that's ruined by the internet you
couldn't do that today at all would have
been ruined in the first 10 second I got
whoo it was ruined for me at the
concession stand buying popcorn somebody
in front of me turned around it was
talking to their friend and they go well
isn't it that he's a ghost in the entire
movie that's terrible that is that isn't
any green junkie fans find out who this
gasps and destroy that ruin their lives
Oh Nick I know you're with me on this
let's talk 90s action real quick okay
well what's great about the 90s is it
probably had the best action movies ever
had the Lethal Weapon sequels it had the
one good die hard sequel it brought us
John Claude Van Damme what do you think
of Michael Mann's Heat
Oh fantastic movie first time Al Pacino
and Robert De Niro shared screen time
guys and rubber masks robbing a bank
I'll take that all day that's steep
that's good times yes boy break
boy break yes boy break Point Break
oh god this lunch is great movies I am
an FBI agent it's about an ex college
football player teaming up a
bank-robbing surfers that's what's great
about the 90s where you could like you
just have like one borderline logline
and then a movie would be made of yeah I
feel like now we live in a world where
an ex college football player and a
surfer wouldn't even give each other the
time of day I know thanks Obama
that is nothing to do with anything Nick
we could just go on and honor their any
movies that we miss that you want to
talk about yeah bottle rocket that was
amazing for me because it was such a
small film but yet I think the budget
was pretty low at that time too so it
was kind of amazing to see that and then
also Boogie Nights kind of it all yeah
sort of like Paul Thomas Anderson's
Goodfellas I would say like the
Goodfellas of porn yeah I love Katie
Anderson I would do anything like if I
would love to work with him
guys we've talked about some awesome 90s
films but there's so many there are so
many good movies in that decade and I
know you're mad because we didn't talk
about your favorite movie so here's some
awesome films that we did not get to
mention
guys what's your favorite 90s movie
leave us an answer in the comment
section below tell us why best answer
you're going to get a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my awesome panel
we get a great conversation about 90
stuff
Rachael Harris Patrick Schumacher Nick
Mundy and don't forget watch surviving
jack on Thursdays on Fox 9:30 8:30
central after American Idol oh one more
thing
Mother's Day is coming up some of you
may know that last year my mom and I
watched the movie human centipede
together two questions would you want to
see my mom back on an episode watching
another weird movie with me and if yes
what movie would that be please let us
know in the comments below I want to
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye his movies called transformers age
of extinction should be called
transformers holy Sh we're doing
Dinobots both the Christ it's really
good